[Music]
all right let's go
out to brandon in meridian brandon
what's up my man
hi dr john thanks for taking my call you
got it brother how can i help
well i've got three major stresses going
on in my life right now and they're all
kind of intertwined and
and they're so jumbled up that i get
myself wrapped around in circles and i
can't
i just shut down and i can't figure out
a way to start
attacking these well thanks for calling
man let's untangle them
what you got okay i've got well the
first
probably most major there um is
my wife and i've been trying to have a
baby for three and a half years now and
so far unable to get pregnant
i've got we're saving to buy a house and
this place that we love
and the goal line keeps moving and it
feels like we're never going to get
to the point where we're going to be
able to buy a house here
i've got a job working for my dad and
he's getting ready to
he wants to exit the business and turn
it over to me and
i'm not sure i want to do that and then
also
even if i don't do that where do i go
from here um
so it's all it's a lot right now and
it's all pretty heavy
and uh and and i'm stuck
well man i appreciate your trust and
give me a call dude that means a lot
um so when here's just a simple
guidelines when i'm in a situation like
you're in
which is both existential and practical
right existential being who am i going
to be am i going to be a dad
am i going to and i've been in that same
that same seat man and then you start
having conversations about adoption and
what does that look like
and then you or your wife feel guilty
and that leads to this whole weird dance
it's just a mess right
um yeah so you've got that number one
and that leads to
i had a picture of what my life was
gonna be which is i'm gonna take over
dad's business in this little community
that we like
we're gonna have 18 little kids running
around and then suddenly
that that picture gets untethered right
it just the string pulls and it starts
to come apart
and then you want to buy a house yeah
and you're right man
we looked for nine months and we still
bought a
kind of a hidden in the woods
fixer-upper-ish kind of you know what i
mean like
yeah yeah because the housing market's
bananas
and so now am i going to be a dad i'm
not going to be a homeowner and then
tell me about your your
your dad's business what's the business
um it's a construction business just a
small company and uh kind of a
niche market but uh we're doing really
well
um so do you want out
i don't know no you do well
i mean in my heart i do but uh but what
do you want to do it's beer based or
what do you want to do
if your dad said hey i just sold the
business to my neighbor for a million
dollars here's half of it
go do what you want he gave you half a
million dollars and said go get them
what would you go do
um
dude you work construction you've been
daydreaming about this for months
if not years what would you go do
oh man i don't know something outdoors i
guess um
something i don't know
it what i feel like i need is is
something that has a little bit more
meaning
um something that uh i feel like i'm
really
making an effect on people okay that's
positive and
so meaning is going to be meaning is
going to be
something you create it's not going to
be an external source
i know guys that have a porta potty
company that have great meaning
like they find value in what they do and
no guys who pour concrete
that find like they they understand that
without them people don't get from point
a to point b
and some yeah dude they just cashed in
and i know other folks yeah who are
public speakers
right they are authors and they're just
clocking in and out they don't find
meaning in that
uh therapists who don't find meaning in
that right
yeah so at the end of the day you've got
to write down these things
on a piece of paper and get them out of
your head because it feels overwhelming
have you done that
um i've started but i haven't really
delved into it now
so here's where this this becomes an
adventure
because i just wrote down unable to get
pregnant
struggling to buy a house family
business
underneath each one of those becomes a
spider web
which is why did i marry her should i
stay married to her if we can't have
kids
is it my fault should i let her go so
she can go to somebody else who has
kids should we adopt like so now all
this looks should i adopt domestically
or locally or
it's 45 000 to adopt a kid in my
neighborhood right if i go private and
if i go
right so you start having those things
and write them down
and then it gets into the family
business i never even wanted to do this
so my dad was
this and i'm living his dream and that's
when these things get hard
right my dad didn't care about me and
you go down these rabbit holes
and that's where you have to write it
all down all of it
all the spiderwebs entangled mess and
then you got to go through those things
and demand evidence from them almost in
a
um i don't know
you gotta back out of it and say
does my dad love me yes is my dad really
passionate about this business yes
does my dad really want me to have it
because he's built this thing and he
wants to pass it off to his son
yes do i have to take it nope
nope and that's scary because now it's
like well then go do whatever you want
to
and that's that's that's terrifying
right
um yeah so there is this weird moment
where
i think it was four years for me and my
wife maybe three and a half
that i i got a job offer in malibu
and we looked at each other and said man
we had this picture of living in texas
and having kids and living this life
let's just go move to malibu the job
came with housing let's just get out of
here
and do something totally off like total
left turn
right and so at some point you and your
wife need to don't have that
conversation
if not this we get to paint a whole new
picture
and it's going to look different you got
to grieve the one that's not but man
there's a lot of really awesome
neighborhoods in the in the world
now meridian's pretty awesome let's be
honest be real it's beautiful
um yeah but there's a lot of cool places
young ago
you can go someplace you move to
nashville for two years and just try
something and then go back
right you can do whatever you want but
you got to go through
the part of untangling that mess in your
heart and head
my gut tells me you don't want to say it
out loud and that's fine i'm going to
keep pressure on you but my gut tells me
is you have a picture
you've been thinking about something a
job you're interested in exploring
in a place that's not where you thought
and either with adopted kids or not
adopted kids
just you and your wife hitting the road
in a camper whatever the thing is
something tells me you've been down that
road and my challenge to you is to step
back and have that conversation with
your wife if you haven't already
and they mean there's not a lot holding
you back how old are you
43 43 yeah
that feels like you're 100 years old but
you're not
well when it comes to kids it feels like
that for sure i know i know
you're probably not even halfway there
yeah
probably not even halfway there
have you sat down and told your dad that
you're thinking about not taking the
business
no uh we're uh we got a meeting set up
in the coming weeks to discuss
what that all looks like do you actually
want it you're just scared of being a
business owner
um well that's the thing i'm trying to
figure out is it just my fear of doing
this
on my own or or is it just something
that i don't want to do
what do you think i'm not letting you
off the hook that easy you can hang up
on me but i don't i
i know that you know that's the thing
man why won't you say it
uh do it say it
say it i've been i've been fearful i
mean i'm
i've always lacked confidence so that's
always been in my
been in my mind about this is it just
because i'm scared
and but at the same time i go to work
every day and i'm i'm just
i mean i'm not happy um i know my guys
feel that i'm not happy um and
i'm creating a an environment that is
not a great place to work just because
of
of me being happy with where i'm at
and it's not right you know how much is
that is
um resting on the heartache of not being
able to grow your family
probably a lot yeah
how's your marriage
we're uh we're good we're we're together
in this you know
um
you can be you can be together in
something but you can be two inches
apart on a couch but
a thousand miles away from each other
man
here's what here's what you sound like
here's what you sound like brandon you
sound like a guy who's totally and
completely alone
and who's 43 and is waking up and going
whoa
whoa suddenly i found myself on an
island
i could be way wrong in that
i'm i don't feel like i'm alone i know
she's there for me and she's
she's she's on this journey with me so
good uh
maybe we're maybe i feel like we're
alone there you go okay
excellent so here's here's the here's
the plan dude
taking over a business yeah you should
be scared man that's scary
not being able to have this picture of
his family that you had yeah that's
terrifying
it's heartbreaking
having to sit down have a hard
conversation with your dad and saying
hey your life's work is something i'm
not interested in i can't even wrap my
head around that conversation
right i just well i'm 40 years old i
just want to get my wife a home
and we can't afford it yeah dude that's
that's a beating
so i want you and your wife to sit down
and
for maybe the first time in a while not
think of the things
that you're lacking that you're missing
that you're
not able to come through on but instead
i want you to say
all right let's take all the blinders
off let's say dad didn't have a business
let's say we
the country was open to us
let's say we we're just gonna call it we
know that we're never gonna have kids
it's just
you and me now what
what kind of crazy adventure could we
build
and i want y'all to lean into that and
you may not fully get there because it's
going to start with tiny houses and
campers and what i don't know whatever
people from idaho do
but it may be you know we don't have to
live here
i've always wanted to live by your
parents or i could run a construction
company in kansas
and for the same price we could buy a
home in meridian i could buy half of a
block in kansas right
whatever that looks like and you begin
to loosen these chains that have wrapped
themselves around you
as you felt yourself losing out on one
thing after another after another after
another
and 43 feels like you're 100 you're not
you're not even halfway there brother
you're not
you man
you deserve somebody who will ride or
die with you
and then you deserve to dream big and go
get it
more practically speaking you need to
have a hard conversation with your dad
sooner rather than later
and ask him to be vulnerable with you
need to sit down with your wife and plan
on okay we've gotta at some point say if
this isn't in the cards for us what's
this gonna look like
right if we can't afford a house in this
community and we want to buy a house
and then at some point the house has to
be more important the community got to
go look somewhere else
that's just that's the math of it right
or we're just going to rent until we're
70 because we're so enamored by this
neighborhood
i'd recommend moving i'd recommend
trying to find something different go
have an adventure if it tanks you can
come back in two years
maybe the housing market will correct
itself in two years whatever that looks
like
but get all the stuff out of your head
all of the derivatives drama all the
tangles
and then start clicking through one at a
time is this true is this true
is this true and then what what of this
can i control i got to let the rest of
it go
and usually what i can control starts
with conversations
hard ones with people i love thank you
so so much for that call brandon you're
a stud dude
now it's time to go do the hard hard
stuff thanks for calling brother